benvenuti in un nuovissimo in video di
oggi parlerà di make up però a
differenza di qualche video fa in cui mi
facevo vedere di make up tremendi quello
del liceo delle media dell'università
oggi voglio farvi vedere un make up che
mi avete chiesto in tantissimi che è il
make up che mi faccio più spesso
ultimamente è nelle mie storie instagram
insomma l'avete visto mi avete scritto
un sacco di messaggi dicendomi che primo
vista va benissimo e quindi mi avete
riempito di complimenti ero tipo o house
infatti mi sta truccando sempre così e e
due di farvi vedere chiaramente i
tutorial per provare anche voi a
truccarvi in questo modo per quanto
riguarda gli occhi uso solitamente
questa palette di 6 foracchia delle
tonalità molto molto news molto toni
neutri insomma sulle quali si può
lavorare bene appunto per un make up di
questo tipo
allora inizierei stendendo questo bel
qui per creare insomma una sorta di
ombreggiatura
secondo step facilissimo il marrone il
marrone lo andiamo a applicare sulla
punta esterna dell'occhio e quindi
andiamo ad accentuare la sfumatura
l'ombreggiatura che avevamo creato con
l'ombretto precedente e andiamo a
scovare i due colori insieme dopo i che
passiamo un colore molto più chiaro
ero andiamo ad applicare sulla nostra
palpebra mobile in particolare nella
zona
insomma centrale o comunque dell'interno
dell'occhio entrano a picchiettare e
vedete che si è creato questo effetto
insomma di sfumato per enfatizzare
ancora di più insomma lo sguardo userei
semplicemente una matita marrone e
andrea ad applicarla
sopra insomma la palpebra mobile
mi raccomando non vi preoccupate anche
se avete fatto una linea troppo spesso
cerca cerchiamo di non far la spesa però
se vi scappa la mano non è un problema
perché poi andremo a sfumarlo con un
pennellino quarto step il mascara in
questo make up diciamo che è il mascara
un ruolo fondamentale perché apre bene
lo sguardo che è già stato enfatizzato
insomma da dall'ombretto dalla matita
con il nostro mascara diamo il tocco
finale e quindi dobbiamo lavorarci un
pochino
concentratevi vedete questi movimenti
dall'alto verso il basso per aprire
meglio le nostre ciglia allungare
andiamo anche a mettere un filo di
mascara sulle nostre ciglia inferiori
per quanto riguarda le labbra potete
optare o per un effetto assolutamente
naturale come nel mio caso ho soltanto
il burrocacao oppure se vi piace
comunque rimanere le tonalità nude ma
senza qualcosa di troppo appariscente io
solitamente uso questo rossetto quasi
mark one love che dà appunto
quell'effetto che è perfetto con questo
make up questo è un alternativa insomma
alle labbra senza rossetto senza di un
tal abramo il nostro make up è finito mi
sono due i capelli così sembra un po più
decente spero tantissimo che questo
video tutorial vi sia piaciuto fatemi
sapere se vi piacciono insomma queste
tipologie di video e soprattutto mi
raccomando se riproducete questo make up
pagatemi nelle vostre foto perché vi
voglio vedere come al solito iscrivetevi
al canale se non l'avete ancora fatto e
attivate la campanella che trovate
vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per
rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti i
miei nuovi video inoltre vi ricordo di
seguirmi su tutti gli altri social
facebook instagram musicale vi mando un
bacione e ci vediamo al prossimo video
[Musica]